Here We Go From The Daily Mail
Biden's non-binary nuclear waste worker
Sam Brinton leaves the department of
energy after being accused of stealing
suitcases from two airports let me stop
you there Daily Mail he wasn't accused
he was criminally charged and he's on
camera doing it you even posted the
videos oh no they didn't post the videos
here maybe uh if we refresh it we'll get
something uh well no there's just him
wearing a dress there we go they posted
the actual photo of him stealing some
woman's luggage so I guess what they're
saying now and then here's him look at
this here's him wearing the shirt in an
airport stealing the bag and then here's
him posting a selfie confirming it was
in fact him wearing this damn that's not
yours put it back so what they're saying
now is
they're saying he's not nine not not
non-binary he gets off on stealing
women's clothes and then wearing them in
public and making people watch him do it
so it's like a klepto fetish thing
that's so weird when this guy joins
really Department well he's on camera
doing it more than once stealing women's
clothing
okay I want you to be right because
that's that's I'm not saying I I know
for sure I'm saying this is what people
are saying now about what's happening
that's a better story than non-binary
the speculation is not binary is boring
now there's plenty of people out there
the speculation is that he steals
women's clothing and gets off on having
people watch him wear it so it's not
about gender identity it's about him
stealing from them and then you know so
it's like Auto gynophilia where he's
just walking around
wait yeah
he's walking around kind of kind of
walking around with someone else's stuff
like semi-hard Auto kleptophilia I don't
know what I don't know I don't know no
that would be like stealing from
yourself
because you're stealing
voyeuristic right is that is that where
you want people to watch you yeah yeah
it'd be a klepto voyeuristic Auto kind
of feeling no exhibitionist no wait is
exhibitionist
because we said before before and
someone claimed like no no you have it
backwards what's the is there a word for
there's not a Euro would be someone that
wants to watch a voye would be someone
that wants to be one so it's
exhibitionist he wants to be watched
yeah so it's exhibitionist klepto Auto
gynophilia he likes attention yeah dude
when he it is it is he right we're not
misgendering him I think that's safe
it's a uh I don't know either sexual
male I just don't want some identifies
this I still want someone to be able to
be like oh you were misgendering him and
like make the focus the fact that there
was a Mischief you focus on sex the
biology of this guy when he was born was
male and I think he is at some point
transitioned his gender to CIS oh yeah
yeah not it's nonsense voyeurism is when
you get off watching other people yeah
so exhibitionist is I think right when
he joined the Biden Administration I was
kind of like the Zen game yes yes I
guess we get people like this with
lipstick ball guy looking weird
he doesn't know what's in this in the
White House
you know it'll be a lot funnier if it
turns out that like his early life story
was that he was like a skydiver and a
snowboarder and he gets off on
adrenaline rushes crazier the better man
so he just like steals women's clothing
the more I love it and then he's like
he's wearing the evidence of his
felonies and he's getting an adrenaline
rush from people watching him do it dude
hey he's a more honest politician than
the other politicians in Washington DC
okay who is the bureaucrat not a
politician he's worse yeah oh man yeah
even still I I'm I mean I have to give
this this story two thumbs up because
I'm enjoying it so much I'm I appreciate
your service now it feels like real like
I've been praying and this is kind of
what happens when you pray is that
people be I'm praying that someone that
works for the government steals women's
bags
people reveal who they really are when
you're deep in prayer with God people
start to reveal who they really are and
people like this this thief is now out
apparent that he's a thief yeah so
that's good this is like stealing
someone's like he stole bags that were
worth thousands of dollars it's like
it's demonic but in not like the worst
way like demonic that freaks me out as
well Monica in the most Bourgeois way
yeah like you know demonic usually I'm
imagining Epstein stuff like high level
demonic satanic evil this is like
Mischief yeah you know
stealing the person's luggage that's
freak it might have been insulin in
there I don't know it might have been
something and that guy didn't even check
in with the bag but walked out with one
well not I don't I don't think insulin
because it has to be refrigerated
probably not inside something
life-saving something put it in the
thermos yeah hopefully you'll check that
stuff but there might be stuff you need
that you can't chat or that you can't
hopefully you'll take all of you yeah
you know people are sometimes they're
addicted to like painkillers so what
happens if someone had their painkillers
inside of you know one of the you know
luggages stealing a bag from a store I
understand it's not it's not like you're
beating someone's face in but stealing
someone's personal belonging is very
different than stealing something from a
store in my opinion evil people man yeah
I'm glad it's crazy like I said I I I'm
happy that it happened because I get to
imbibe the story and enjoy it but that's
the extent of it so he's on leave now no
longer an employee
and that's just and criminally charged
yeah your employees what going to prison
gonna get locked up well it depends on
Larson Attorney that he gets the crazy
thing is apparently the first time
Brenton got caught doing this he told
the cop like oh I accidentally grabbed
the wrong bad bag and didn't realize it
and then I panicked because people
thought I stole it so I just left it and
then I brought it back to the airport or
whatever and it's like bro you're on
camera with no bag and that was the day
he didn't he didn't check a bag
you go to the airport no bag and you
take someone's bag we know you stole it
yep at the very least you know like he
could get a uh a generic black travel
bag but the dude just not even smart
enough to do that he got caught twice
now imagine how many times he wasn't
caught because how many times will
officers or security actually go through
the whole footage actually look at uh
the whole scenario and actually do a
full investigation to find out who stole
a luggage bag I mean I I had a bag once
missing and they were like yeah screw
you tough luck yep so how many times did
he get away with it is the larger
question I want it to be double digits
and I want to hear about every one of
them
I would I'd be willing to bet the
clothing he's wearing all the time his
clothing he stole from women
God I hope that's true
because I think the whole larious crazy
story I just like the fact that it's a
crazy chaotic story like so outlandish
this this person gets hired and then
just flies around the country stealing
people's bags and wears clothing of the
opposite sex and and wears a lot of
weird dog stuff too I mean oh yeah
there's a lot of dog stuff yeah a lot of
dog masks I I love him I love him bald
dude with lipstick he looks like Matt
Damon too
absolutely like sorry Matt or
congratulations Matt
congratulations nice job guys yeah he
looks like a bald Matt Damon maybe Matt
can play him in the movie oh there we go
it'll be the older Britain is that his
name the older Prince about the dude
who's the whole luggage from the airport
yeah
how did I get here
Phil's dying get it you can't do it
can we hire Matt Damon to do this maybe
at some point did he do an FDX he did
not oh he did I don't know but no he did
a crypto commercial was it was it I
don't know
commercial that was crypto.com
people are getting sued Like Larry David
for this FTX thing Larry David are they
actually getting sued do you guys know I
don't know I think so but it's kind of
dumb like doing a commercial is not the
same as like running and committing the
fraud you know for sure yeah like
there's no way these guys knew this it's
a crypto exchange yeah and the exchange
outwardly said they were going to do it
righteously and they lied if the if this
change had been saying they're gonna do
it illegally and then you know Tom Brady
was still doing commercials for him he'd
be implicated in my opinion
well Tom Brady was an investor he's
probably super angry about that I mean
just like not only the people that had
no money in FTX but it's also the people
that were investors you know that's why
him and uh Giselle are getting divorced
yeah she's mad she's like I can't
believe you Tom no no she was she was
the one who pushed him to do it that
idea and she's like just do it I'm the
one that makes the money in this family
here with your stupid football
she makes so much more money than he
does he was able to take a low contract
because of that yeah the Patriots have a
huge amount of money to spend on players
nice I got a uh you know Media Matters
is mad at me because I I was talking
about what story were we talking about I
think it was Elon or something yeah it's
the Elon story I said woke people want
companies to keep on bad employees based
on their identity yeah they do and and
the left guy mad at me for saying that
but I'm like but that's a fact statement
that's your that's true Media Matters is
always mad at someone they're they're I
my favorite person in Media Matters is
the girl that watches Tucker Carlson her
whole job is just to watch Tucker
Carlson and be a [ __ ] and I'm like
you're the best I love her she's great
who is it her name her name's Kat yeah
and she works for Media Matters her job
is to watch Tucker Carlson and be and
just be a complete we should do that we
should just hire someone well there are
people that do that I mean there's
there's people that watch like medium
like media matter stuff and like Sean
actual Justice Warrior he's great all
his job is just a sh crap all over The
Young Turks we got we got to do like a
Mystery Science Theater thing with MSNBC
where we just get like people to watch
it and comment on it in real time it
would be so much fun probably get three
comedians just watch you know Rachel
Maddow specials Joy Reid I wouldn't
enjoy read I wouldn't wish on anyone are
you kidding me that's totally hilarious
yeah seriously Joy Reed says the most
ridiculous [ __ ] it would be freaking
awesome to have three Silhouettes just
sitting there trashing every ridiculous
thing that comes out of her mouth
Joy Reid huh yeah she's great she got
hacked once
oh wait you remember that story oh she
actually tweeted something and then said
it was a hack no she posted a Blog that
was like opposing gay marriage or
something yeah and then she's like they
they hacked me they hacked me
then you want to be like who's they Joy
but who's they though
what do you mean Joy that's the crazy
thing about uh uh modern cancel culture
stuff is that these people know
that the top the whims of the left
rotate randomly and so they have to say
something today that they have to
disagree with tomorrow
so then they just deny it I'd break up a
reason I didn't really say that I was
hacked
like is it is a system that's trying to
constantly uh subvert the system and if
the system changes it needs to create a
different type of subversion so you're
always the continuous Revolution as soon
as something becomes
old as soon as something becomes the
norm or part of the status quo then it
becomes counter-revolutionary and so
they have the the revolutionaries have
to oppose anything that's considered uh
status quo
so it's all it's all about constantly
performing the dialectic or constantly
pushing the envelope constantly being a
revolutionary that's why when you listen
to like uh when you listen to old videos
of like Castro talking or whatever he's
always talking about counter
revolutionaries and the revolution
continues like the revolution happened
Castro got into power in Cuba and then
you listen to the Castro talk for the
next whatever 60 or whatever years
however long he was he was alive it's
the revolution the revolution the
revolution the revolution it's
continuous it it's it's constant if it
stops if the revolution ends then it
becomes the status quo it becomes
conservative it becomes the old things
and the bad you know and that's all the
bad stuff according to you know the
revolutionaries so staying on the
offensive psychologically I I think that
might be might be accurate I'm not sure
if that's the way they conceive of it
um but if you're a revolutionary leftist
then you need to make sure that the
revolution is continuous somebody said
that Biden's person looks like the
daughter from Coneheads
that's the first thing I thought when I
saw this guy
oh okay all right but I don't think they
look alike they just have Coneheads yeah
they all have lipstick on I'm going to
stand on principle and not mock people
that are bald thank you very much
I am in no position to mock anyone yeah
that's that's not it though is it a
cone-shaped head or not that's the
question and but more importantly the
the young woman who well actually I
don't think she's young anymore but the
one who played the daughter in the
conehead doesn't look like that guy
what's who is that not at all yeah
someone just super chatted that they
were like looks like the daughter I
don't know he does have like a very
conical stream side by side I wanna part
of me wants to make fun of Sam Brinton
because I he I think he looks like funny
kind of like you know he wears big bald
head lipstick wearing women's clothes
like that for me
yeah
I want to stay focused on the crime that
the Biden Administration puts someone
into there I believe because of his
sexual identity or his gender identity
and then it turns out it's a thief has
made it clear that identity is the is
the most important thing and he made it
clear before he was the president he
made it clear when he said that he was
going to pick a uh a person of color
woman that a woman of color to be his
running mate he specifically said that
before he picked uh Kamala Harris like
out like there's there was no no
no ambiguity to it it was purely said
that he was going to select a woman of
color identity has been a defining
Factor throughout the whole Biden
Administration whether or not you
approve of that is a different topic but
you can't deny the fact that the Biden
Administration has made identity a
definitive uh uh aspect when it comes to
hiring yeah no question about it in
Jean-Pierre yeah he's terrible at her
job I know they cared about her skin
color her sexuality like that what you
just need I mean I don't know her
personally but she's obviously lying
she's terrible at her job she looks like
she's lying a lot of times and doesn't
answer a question repeats herself goes
uh uh uh you know like dude I mean but I
mean what can you do at that point are
you gonna be like yeah actually the
administration's full of it you can't I
mean you're supposed to be the
mouthpiece of the dog you know I don't
know Katie mcenany
she went and she did a really really
great job and Donald Trump did his
absolute best to throw that poor woman
under the bus every chance he got if you
listen to to Kaylee mcenany like dodging
not just the Press but also dodging
stuff that Donald Trump said that she
just found out about that she didn't
know about she was really really good
and she had to deal with not only a
hostile press but Donald Trump who was
completely and totally unpredictable for
for uh um a press secretary you watch
the way that she behaved compared to the
way that Jean-Pierre does her job and it
is striking the difference in
professional preparedness that Kaylee
mcanini had compared to Korean John
Prieto I get this vibe that the the
reporters in the room with her are like
I'm so lucky to be here if I upset the
queen we will be ostracized and and
banished and so when when Korean gets
angry if you see her her face or get
contort like that's her about to be like
you're out of here if you do if you
don't shut up you're out of here I
imagine that the DNC the people that
that are in the The Press Room in the
White House are mostly Democrats and
they don't want to I mean it's all about
access they don't want to upset the
access that they have they don't want to
upset the the administration because if
the administration is upset with them
then they might get kicked out they
might not get the good beat they might
not get the leads they might not get the
people in the administration calling
them saying hey I've got a scoop for you
etc etc that's just the way that that
kind of stuff goes when you're in those
positions accesses everything and if you
up set the president or the
administration the administration cuts
off your access and if you don't have
access then you're not valuable to the
admin the organization that you're
supposed to be the white house uh you
know liaison for or whatever thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time